hello
everybody my clickbaity title has worked
fantastic welcome to open API you're
doing it wrong and I would just like to
thank each and every one of you
individually for coming to my talk
because I don't have very much content
so hi Morton thank you hi what's your
name
no I'm kidding
uh yeah no this is uh this is a talk
that popped into my head uh at the end
of last year where I was working where
I'm still working where we have a lot of
apis we're an API first company lots of
teams working on apis that other teams
will call and mostly those are HTTP apis
internally they call them rest apis
they're not rest apis
no apis are rest apis rest was a stupid
idea and we're not doing it now we just
use rest API to refer to any API that's
Json over HTTP but it's not rest it's um
it's open API and as dot net developers
the killer burning question for all of
us when it comes to open API and Swagger
is should I use swashbuckle or should I
use n swag and I am here to answer that
question once and for all
okay I don't have anything against
the people behind swashbuckle and then
swag and what they do they do well and
it's better than nothing it's better
than just not having Swagger for your
project but it is missing the point of
open API it's missing the point of
swagger and I'm hoping over the next 58
minutes to convince you of that and send
you a way to do things differently so
let's start off by talking about what
open API is because
as dot net developers you include
swashbuckle or end swag in your startup
code for your ASP netcore project and
you put the attributes on things and
then something happens and your website
your API magically has a slash Swagger
slash UI
index.html page you don't know where it
came from but it shows your API if you
set it up properly it makes it possible
to call your API and and run test things
against it
not many people in the.net world look at
the actual
openapi.json file that is being
generated underneath that that's the
actual documentation of your API so
let's start we'll talk about the open
API versions so open API 2.0 was Swagger
so there was Swagger
um one and Swagger 2.0 and then Swagger
2.0 they said okay this is going to be a
standard we're going to call it open API
people are going to collaborate on it
and then so the next version was not
called Swagger it was called open API
3.0 this is the current version this is
the thing that's supported by all the
tooling uh and and everything else
that's out there there is an open API
3.1 which is new and improved and we'll
talk about the main difference there
later on and there is a speculative open
API 4.0 which currently has the code
name moonwalk and we'll look at that
later on as well but for the time being
right now if you want the best
experience you should use open API 3.0
fun fact this is the first time I've
done this presentation where I
remembered to make this slide already
have everything remove the animation on
the slide because it used to go open and
then all the versions would disappear
and it would just have to use this one
Arrow so yay me third time fourth time
lucky
so how do we Implement open API well
like I say in.net we had a bunch of
attributes to our MVC controllers or we
had a bunch of dot this dot that dot the
other method calls on the end of our
minimal API definitions and we say okay
so this is an ad and it's a post method
and it produces 201 with a type of book
and we just
fill our codes with attributes I see a
lot of apis where what they're actually
doing is incredibly simple they've got a
DB context being injected they get a
record by ID and this is a whole other
talk they then return the Entity
framework class so that it can be
serialized adjacent don't do that either
but I'm not going to get into that now
so you end up with this situation where
to get a quality open API description of
the project there's more lines of code
given over to those attributes than
there is to the functionality of your
code which is just weird and wrong you
get methods that won't fit on a page
because the attributes section is is
running at like 30 of the things
everywhere else in the node world in the
python world in the Ruby world in in all
the other places when they do open AP I
think some Java things might now do the
reflection-based stuff but most uh teams
particularly in the dynamic world where
it can't make inferences about types and
generate Json schemas and that sort of
thing they write their open API file by
hand usually in the yaml unless they
really hate themselves
and then they build the application to
match their open API dot yaml file they
are hand crafted artisanal yaml files
that people maintain and Source control
and I know some people uh sort of got
yaml fatigue at this point if you're
using Docker or particularly if you're
using kubernetes because you've got your
kubernetes resource files and you've got
your Helm charts and you've got this and
that and the other and then you've got
your CI CD pipelines with GitHub actions
or as your devops which is another
crapload of yaml there's yaml all over
the place and you just you don't want
another piece of yaml in your life just
deal with it it's always going to be all
yaml files all the way down uh when we
get to webassembly running in little web
assembly containers we're still going to
have yaml manifests for them so just
it's fine let's just use a gamble it's
the absolute worst data serialization
and structuring format except for all
the others we've tried
I still remember I've been doing this
not speaking at conferences
um and but I have been uh professional
software developer since 1990 so that's
33 years
um when we first started when I was
started out with Infamous 4gl and wise
Terminals and sco xenix and that sort of
stuff uh we had waterfall we had ssadm
we had prints too there was a process
and business analysts would generate
specifications and then analyst
programmers would then turn those
specifications into code and we actually
used to say wouldn't it be really nice
we used to use lint to check that our C
was going to compile before we tried to
compile it because lint would run in
about two minutes and the bills used to
take two and a half hours and we played
table tennis and when you say wouldn't
it be great if you could lint the spec
if you could check that the spec was
correct if there was some kind of
compile step that the spec could go
through because it was Word documents or
it was text it wasn't Word documents
this was 1990. there were text documents
they were they were just unstructured
and now we actually have a spec format
that you can lint and it will tell you
if there are errors and you can check
that it's right and it's called open API
and when we're building Json over HTTP
apis this is our specification
I actually see people so they go oh
we're going to use swashbuckle we're
going to use n swag to generate our open
api.json file but we need the spec for
the API so they write the spec in
markdown in the GitHub repository and
what you're doing is you're writing here
open API yaml file in markdown with
headers instead of sections and
everything else
and it's this is something we've been
brought to expect in the world of dot
net and I blame WCF
um I blame WCF for many many things
including my failure to achieve
Microsoft certification
because I I breathed The Entity frame
and various components I could not
because it kept asking me questions
about the configuration files and uh
server config and everything else
um but uh the main reason why I blame
WCF is that the thing it did uh 90 of
the time when we use WCF we were
building a soap service and the idea was
that you would write your contract using
C sharp and decorate it with some
attributes and then it would generate
this ship this is wisdal uh web service
definition language
and this in eight point font is just uh
two messages uh and one operation with
an input and and so yeah if you actually
built a WCF service that had like a
service with let's say 15 methods on it
that wisdal file would just be
impenetrable XML going on for page after
page and so
in that context yeah okay that was good
nobody wants to hand maintain a wisdal
file but then we got used to this idea
that these API definitions were going to
be generated for us and so we've ended
up with swashbuckle and end swag and uh
and also grpc
um the alternative implementation of
grpc which Mark gravel does got a lot of
respect for Mark he's a great programmer
but his grpc implementation is from hell
and you shouldn't use it
um so
why am I so against this
so your open API file and I'm going to
say it's just the yaml file don't do the
Json way but it's the source of Truth
for your team okay this is what you have
agreed that your API should look like
and if you can have that in a single
file a single formattable highlightable
text file that you can all compare and
if you want to make changes to the
design of the API you can do it in one
place and you can view it without having
to clone and build and run the
application so that you can actually get
the Json file out of it that can be your
specification that is what you have all
agreed this is
um
this is the key point if you are using
swashbuckle or n swag your design and
your implementation are the same thing
if you want to change the design you
have to change the implementation
there's no two-step process now for some
things if you're working on a quick and
dirty API and it's just you maybe that's
okay but you know hands up if you are
actually just working on a quick and
dirty API and it's just you in your day
job hands up if you're part of a team
working on an API
yeah there we go hands up if your arms
don't work
but yeah you sit around and you argue
and you say
this should return this type of object
it should have these properties it
should have this list of other objects
inside it and then we need to support a
get and a put and a post and we should
have a get with a list and a get with an
ID that gets a specific one and maybe we
want a way of querying it and posts
should return 201 and puts should return
202 no they shouldn't they should return
a 201 if it's created or a 200 if it was
already there and we've updated it and
no it shouldn't it should return a 204
no content 90 of the meeting will
obviously be which variant of a 200
return code you're actually returning
but when you have decided and agreed it
it goes into your open api.yaml file
okay
didn't sort that one out
better description I can't no idea how
to mess with the animations on them on
PowerPoint uh but I can build apis
so it is a better description of your
API than can be generated by nswag or
swashbuckle
theoretically possible if you know the
magic incantations and all the
attributes and all the extension methods
and all the options that you can put
into the startup code to set almost
every part of an open API
description that can be set it's just it
gets really difficult for some of them
and there's other things you can do in a
yaml file like for example yaml files
support comments
and I haven't found anything in N swag
or swashbuckle that will let you add
comments into your output Json or yeah
well certainly not in your Json but into
your output yaml file
and we can do automated documentation of
this as well and I'm going to show
examples of that later on and when I say
documentation I don't mean Swagger UI I
mean some actual really nice static
documentation files uh that you can
publish that will then get people off
your back and stop saying Hey how do I
call this from curl how do I call this
from python
so I'm going to this this is grpc
actually this is just Proto buff
uh the way protobuf works and grpc works
this is cross-platform It's supported by
almost everything and you write a Proto
file and I've been doing a workshop for
a few years now on how to do grpc in.net
using this protofile approach and you
define your messages and you define your
services and then the compiler generates
stubs for those uh those assets so it
generates the classes for the messages
and it generates a base class for the
service and then it uh you you can use
that and all the serialization code is
pre-generated and so it works really
well with Native iot and that sort of
thing
um but you can see here this is uh the
money type this is from Google's public
apis uh that they use for things like
AdSense and double click and so forth
and they there's no decimal type in
protobuf they have double and Float
which obviously isn't great for money
and so they have this money type which
has a currency code and a units and a
memos and this is the file that they
publish if you download money.proto from
the Google apis uh site and this is it
and you can see it's got comments in
here it's saying okay string currency
code uh telling you that it's a string
is not particularly useful telling you
that it's defined in ISO 4217 means you
can go and find a pirated copy of
iso4217 somewhere because ISO charge for
access to their bloody standards and
then it explains that the whole units of
the amount and the Nanos of the amount
it tells you how those are working you
can put comments in there and you can't
do that with using n swag or swashbuckle
but if you're writing a yaml file by
hand you can put as many comments as you
like in there
so
I mentioned earlier that I think the
majority of net developers and by the
way if you're already doing this then
the total uh the title of the talk was
wrong and I love you and you're awesome
and carry on doing it
um and but if you arguing with somebody
uh then you can point them and go look
Mark rindall says you should do it this
way and so that must be true
uh
if you're using swashbuckle if you're
using n swag there's a very good chance
that you don't have the faintest idea of
what's actually in that file that it
generates whether it's Json or yaml and
so we're going to take a look at the
actual structure of open API uh and and
how you would build it out
so we start off at the top we have kind
of like our header and we tell the we're
telling the text editor essentially at
this point this is open API 3.0 so use
those linting rules and intellisense and
so forth and then we have an info
section there's a bunch of stuff that
can go in here but we've got a title and
a version that's kind of like the bare
minimum and then we can put our contact
information in there as well including
my email address which is now on YouTube
that's going to be fun and I'll just
draw attention to it in case anybody
didn't notice
uh and then we can define tags as well
and we'll come back to tags uh in a
little while
and then the top level kind of set of
items uh in an open API document is your
paths
so we have a paths section and then we
just put in the Uris so here we've got
slash red slash books and we say this
has got a get method on it and that is
the HTTP method so you're going to have
get put post patch delete
Etc
operation ID sadly optional your open
API file will lint perfectly well
without an operation ID but you really
should put one in there it's very
helpful we have a summary and you can
actually put markdown in there you can
tell it do the yaml thing for a
multi-line string which I think is a
pipe and then you just do a text
following that and so you can
write as much as you want about what
this method is doing what this endpoint
is doing we say which of the tags this
is part of so this is part of our books
tag and then we Define our responses and
we say Okay so we've got a 200 response
we're going to put that in quotes
because yaml can do weird things if you
use numbers as property names so we'll
put 200 in there we'll say the
description of that is okay
and
then we drill into our response
so we can specify the content of our
response and we can actually specify
different descriptions of That content
based on media types ninety percent of
the time you're just going to say
application slash Json but if you're
working in a place where you've got Java
programmers in the early 2000s are
calling your service then you could put
application slash XML or some other
format in there as well
and then we can specify a schema and in
this case to make it fit on the screen
I'm just using a reference and we can
also specify examples and that's really
nice as well
that means that in the documentation
when it's generated instead of going oh
this one's a number one one one one one
this one's a string quote string quote
it will actually use realistic looking
examples of your domain
schema
schema is basically adjacent basically
Json schema okay so we have schema type
object properties so it's written in the
Apple but it's Json schema and yaml is
Json but without the quotes and curly
braces and with significant white space
they are the underlying representation
is essentially the same you can use Json
inside the animal you can use Json
arrays and all sorts of weird stuff but
we have schema so the type of this is
object it has some properties uh type ID
title and author those are strings
finished at is a string but the format
of it is a date time because Json
doesn't understand dates so we have to
say this is going to be a date time so
that means that'll be an uh an ISO 8601
date format on there
and we can put that in line or we can
put it somewhere else and we can
reference it so yes and
uh it's it's Json schema but okay so the
difference uh the primary difference
between open API 3.0 and open API 3.1 is
that in 3.1 it actually is Json schema
it follows the same rules the same
validation same everything else in 3.0
it's kind of a subset bit of a superset
call it a variant of Json schema it's
pretty much the same unless you're doing
very weird things you're not going to
run into uh issues with that
okay
and then we have our parameters that are
being passed in to our
um our methods and so here we've got our
path is uh Slash red slash book slash ID
um in curly braces it's the same format
as is used in almost every routing
system certainly the same as is used
in.net or ASB net core so this gets it
actually gets the details of a completed
book but we have our parameters list
here and we see Name ID so that's
linking it to that ID part from the path
there we tell it it's in the path and
you can also say in body or in headers
in there as well and then we can put a
schema in there since this is in our
path it's obviously just going to be a
simple type like an INT or a string but
if it's in the body then it could
potentially be a full Json schema is it
required yes
and uh
that's uh yeah
that's how parameters work I thought I
had something else to say there but I
don't
okay
so requests
if we have a post operation it's got a
request body if we have a put operation
it probably has a request body and so
here we can have a request body and we
can say we can specify the content and
the application type and so forth we can
have a schema in here we can also have a
required section on our object schema
here that says you have to put in title
and author otherwise we're going to send
you a 400 bad request response
and so we can put that in there as well
so
an API
uh if I've got my my sort of done that
API which is what I'm using as an
example here done that is I don't like
to do lists because they're incredibly
stressful and it's too much pressure so
I'm creating a done list so after I've
done something I can just arbitrarily go
I did that but I haven't got anything
saying oh you need to do that I just go
yay I have succeeded so I get all the
gratification and and benefit and
endorphins of marking something is done
with it never having been there marked
as not yet done so this is this all
comes from that so this is kind of like
add a distance for a run or a walk or
something and obviously the properties
of a distance would be a title and an
author and I didn't just completely
screw up my code samples
one day I'll give this talk and I'll
have fixed all this instead of just
calling it out like an idiot uh but
today is not that day
um so yes
but like one of the things in there is
books which do have a title and an
author and a date that I finished it at
and if I get a list of books then the
response type the schema is going to be
booked if I get a single book then the
response type is going to be booked if I
post a book the request type is is going
to be booked I don't want to repeat that
all over the place and so we have
components and I'm going to switch over
at this point to
Visual Studio code
and I'm going to move this onto here
where he and we're going to close
that
and we're going to zoom in
okay
so this is can you see that at the back
it's a big screen should be able to so
yeah here we have our books and our
authors and our distances and our users
um and so you can see here that I've got
this dollar ref list of books and
components examples lists of books right
down at the bottom of this API here I
have a component section so this is the
other top level section you have info
paths and components there's one or two
others but these are the main ones
within here we have various different
types of reusable components so we have
examples here and we can see the list of
books uh the value of that is two
objects each with an ID a title and an
author
um and we have a single entry for
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy and
Mort
um and then we have a schemas section
and we have a book here
that has a
an IED and a title and a finish that and
we have a new book which just has a
title and an author and we have our list
of books which is an array and we can
reference things inside here
and so on and so on all the way down to
the bottom there
okay
the things that we can stick in
components are these schemas so our Json
schemer objects responses and request
bodies we can put those in there so we
don't have to keep redefining a response
parameters so if we've frequently got an
ID parameter for example and we're using
guides across our entire system for our
IDs then we can define an IED which is a
type string and format uuid and then
reuse that across the entire system
headers so location headers or content
type headers that sort of thing security
schemes we'll take a look at in a minute
examples which are really good and make
your documentation look a lot better
links and callbacks I've not used those
in anger so but they're in there I'm not
100 sure what they're for but if you
need them I figure you'll figure it out
So This Is How We Do components we have
that component section at the end of the
file and then we reference those using a
dollar ref property underneath so if we
say we're referencing a schema we say
schema colon and then a property inside
that that says dollar ref and points to
where the actual schema object is so I I
get confused with that sometimes until
I've sort of got a couple of examples
and I go sort of content application
slash Json and then dollar ref right
away no doesn't work it doesn't know
what I'm referencing
the other thing you can do and as you
get to a point where you've got a bigger
API and more people working on it is you
can actually reference external files so
you can dump your schema into individual
yaml files or Json files you can
reference these as Json as well and then
you can just import it in so if the
reference starts with a pound symbol or
a hash symbol if you're not American why
did I say Pound symbol
my God I'm British that's not a pound
symbol it's a hash or a sharp anyway so
that will look in the existing file
under component slash schemas uh if it
doesn't start with a hash then it will
look for an actual file uh with a path
relative to the current file
so one of those things that I had in
that list of components is actually
security this is something that I really
don't see often enough in uh Swagger uis
for people who were doing
um swashbuckle or or n swag is quite
tricky to set it up and tell it how to
do authentication so in our
component section we can have a security
schemes section and then we can Define
schemes within that our application
supports so I've got my API it's using
auth zero to let you authenticate
because I am made of money sorry author
um
but no it's it could be identity server
could be anything else but I can say the
type is oauth 2 there's a few types that
can go in there and then I can specify
the flows that are supported so we've
got implicit where it will redirect you
over to this authorization URL and this
specifies the Scopes that are going to
be requested when you go over to that
and we also have client credentials and
we have a token URL that you can go to
with a client ID and a client secret and
get back a bearer token that you can use
to access the API and then I can
actually on the top of my
um
open api.yaml file here another top
level thing and I can say security
and the security scheme for this is auth
zero and then empty array so it is
possible to put more things in there but
I just want the property name in the
yaml the best way to kind of just have a
key that just means something by its
presence but doesn't have a value is to
use an empty array for some reason
okay
your API is going out there into the
world and people are going to call it
and if there's one thing I've learned
about people in my 50 years of existence
it's that uh
so I can go two ways here
they're stupid
is is the mean way of doing it it's no
people make mistakes and they're going
to call your API and they're not going
to have formed their request object
properly or they URL properly or
something is going to be wrong with the
requests that they send you or maybe
you've made a mistake and something goes
wrong and an exception gets thrown or
maybe you're relying on an external
service like a database or a redis cache
or a blob S3 storage or blob storage all
sorts of things can go wrong and you
need a way to communicate to the person
calling your API that something has gone
wrong
if somebody has sent you an object which
has got sort of in total with nesting
and everything else 80 properties okay
and you're trying to you validate it and
go are all these properties okay and one
of them isn't and your response to that
person is 400 bad requests no content
that's not very helpful
so there is a sort of standard it's kind
of I'm not sure it's actually maintained
by anybody but it is agreed upon there's
a standard format for returning problems
in Json the mime type for it is
application slash problem plus Json
um and it looks roughly like this we
have a problem details it's got an
object we say as a type so what type of
problem is it is it an internal server
error is it an external provider error
is it uh something wrong with your
object error uh we have a and that would
normally so the purists would say that
should be a fully qualified URL ideally
it would point to an HTML page that
describes that type of error Nobody Does
that we have the title and the details
so that's where you put in the text for
the user to read the consumer to read we
have the status that's the HTTP status
code we have an instance which is like a
trace ID so like
activity.current.id you can put that in
there and then we have objects which is
essentially a dictionary but in Json a
dictionary is just another object with
properties and so forth and then we have
extensions which is where you can put
whatever the hell you like and we have
an example of this here so
um
it this does actually point to an RFC
7231 one or more validation errors
occurred uh and 400 we've got our Trace
ID in there but we've also got in errors
uh the way to fill this out if it's a
bad request is for each property that
there was a problem with you use that as
a key and then you put in a string list
a list of strings of things that were
wrong with that property so maybe it's
really weird when you can have more than
one problem with the same property I
struggled to think of of scenarios for
that but you could have more than one uh
problem with it you go this is too long
and Too Short
um make it exactly the right length
so yes
okay
um so let's jump back to uh this code
here and we can see if I look at post
we've got a 400 and it will return this
400 bad request so we can go up and we
can open
uh we've got a responses folder here and
we've got a 400 bad request
um and this content type is application
problem plus Json and we have a
validation problem details yaml and then
we can specify this in here and say
what's going on there I also have a 201
created
and if we return according to proper
HTTP API things if you have created
something
joins me nuts that the created method in
an MVC controller you can pass in the
object and it'll serialize it back into
the response which is not really the way
you're supposed to do it you return a
201 created and then you set a location
header and say this is where you can do
a get if you want to refetch that object
and find out what id I assigned to it
magically or that sort of thing
so in headers here we just have a
location header and we can see this is
the absolute URI of the created record
and it's it's a string because of course
it is it's a header okay
so yeah we have this problem details and
then any request that
has a post or a put or anything like
that has the potential to return problem
details
um except for some reason this one okay
all this code is on GitHub by the way so
um don't worry too much if you're not
managing to write it all down as I
scroll through it
okay
so that's open API 3.0 that's where we
are at the moment
um when I
uh went on Twitter and said I'm doing a
new talk to tell.net developers to stop
using swashbuckle and end swag Daryl
Miller who is on the open API working
group uh sent me a DM and said yeah good
luck with that
but he pointed me at some stuff that
they're working on and one of the things
they're working on is open API 4.0 which
is currently called moonwalk and
it attempts to fix some problems with
open API 3.0 and it does it fixes them
in in a nice way
um
the key thing here is that we have paths
and we have red slash books and we have
our tags but then below that instead of
having get put post delete whatever we
have requests and then what used to be
operational ID becomes a top level key
in a yaml and then within that we
specify that the method is get and the
description and responses and everything
else is pretty much the same except in
responses instead of using the status
code we say there is an OK response
which will be status 200 there may be
other responses
the
key difference here and the thing that
this recognizes that open API 3.0
doesn't recognize is that you can have
polymorphic endpoints so you could have
an end point where you post something to
it and if you post
object Foo then it will do one thing and
if you post object bar it will do
another thing and if you post object
Wibble it will do another thing and
those three things will all return
different responses now in open API 3.0
you say post and then you can specify
multiple possible content types that
they could post and you could specify
multiple possible response types that it
will return but there's no way of saying
if you post this you'll get that if you
post this you'll get that and if you
post this you'll get that open API for
moonwalk lets you say you can post to
the same URL different objects and the
behavior will be different and it allows
you to describe that and the response is
okay there also allows you to say okay
I'm going to have three different ways
that I describe a 400 bad request to you
so I'm going to separate out whether
it's a server Ferreira an external
dependency error or you've done
something wrong and you can have you can
name those and you can give them
different descriptions
okay
there's some really neat tooling out
there for open API for people who are
generating this stuff
um they're Swagger UI that's the thing
that everybody's seen okay that's the
thing
the swashbuckle and end swag magically
add to your API application Swagger UI
is great it's still called Swagger UI
it's not called open API UI because
Swagger is still a trademarked name uh
belonging to Smart bear
and so the UI is still called Swagger
the underlying document is called open
API
so we all know about that one but then
there's uh there's redoc and this allows
you to do interesting things with your
yaml or Json files from the command line
uh like for example bundling so you can
if you've got like I have in my sample
code everything broken up into lots of
different files uh you want to bundle
that compile it into a single file uh
for deployment along with your website
to drive swaggy UI Swagger UI won't
follow links between files apart from
anything else and so redoc allows you to
bundle everything into a single file it
also will generate a yaml file and a
Json file from the same source as well
we just with The Shins and re-slate is a
way of generating documentation uh based
on redoc will also generate static
documentation files so it's basically an
HTML file with some inline CSS and
JavaScript that then loads your
um
Json file and turns into a lovely
documentation page with a shins and
resellate is another way of doing that
it's uh sort of pythony node sort of
solution and then there's elements and
I'm going to show you elements in a
minute because I love elements it's
great
in terms of actually working with this
stuff uh vs code there are multiple
extensions for working with open
api.yaml files the one that I recommend
is by 42 crunch okay
they're all okay but the 42 crunch one
has just been the most stable uh
provides the best intellisense provides
the best red squiggles all that sort of
thing if you're using jetbrains Rider
you just have open API support is built
in out of the box and also if you're
using jetbrain's Rider if you've
actually got an open API file in your
project it will do magical things it
lights up it generates test code for you
it does all sorts of insane stuff it's
it generates like a postman style thing
for calling your API just from having
that file there
so bundling
reedokley is an npm package
and so you do npm install minus G re
dockly and wait while it downloads the
internet somewhere into your valuable C
drive where you don't have very much
space and then you can do this from the
command line
uh so that will follow all the links and
then it will embed any referenced files
it'll just move those into components
rewrite those refs so that you have a
single file uh for deploying to your
application
okay so I said I was going to show you
elements I'm going to show you uh the
other thing that I really like about
this
I'm going to zoom in because that's
ridiculous
okay
um
this is the code so note that down
that's where you can get the stuff from
the uh
slides will be in there after the talk
as well I'll do that before I shut up
and leave
so yes
uh if you're Json file if you're yaml
file if your Json file is generated by
swashbuckle or end swag and people go
how do I get the documentation for your
site and you go uh clone this run it or
go to the actual thing running in
production and look at the Swagger UI
and that's the documentation if you have
it as a source controlled item which you
should be doing anyway because as I say
this is your agreed design and your
source of Truth for your project for
your developers to be working from but
if you have that in your GitHub
repository you can just do some very
simple GitHub actions and I mean simple
and you can generate the documentation
into GitHub pages and then when someone
comes along you can actually on your
readme file say oh look here's the
documentation
and it's not a complicated GitHub action
it is so you have to go through the
thing of saying
um
I'm going to show this in code instead
because that looks horrible
uh no I don't
go away
right
so this is our GitHub workflow we need
write permission because we're going to
be modifying a branch and we have build
and deploy so install and build step we
can use npx so node is pre-installed on
all GitHub workers so we can use npx
which says don't actually install this
package just download it cache it
locally run it and then trash it so we
say npx redox CLI bundle open API blah
blah blah and then we can use this
deploy GitHub action which James Ives
whoever he is wrote which will take our
dist folder from the current directory
and copy it into a branch the GitHub
Pages branch in this particular case
that's it that runs on every check-in
and then if I go back to here and I can
show you the two
documentation options so I'll show you
redoc first
okay I hope that looks better on the big
does that look better on the big screen
because it looks like hell down here
that's sort of readable isn't it but um
yes so this is uh this is redoc and we
get a lovely uh sort of set of
documentation here
um we can go to different sections here
and remember earlier on I mentioned tags
and why they're useful so
Swagger uis that are generated by n swag
or swashbuckle unless you know that
there is a tag attribute that you can
add to controllers for example or
methods action methods it'll just be a
massive list of uh end points if you put
tags into your open API it breaks those
down into sections in Swagger so you can
see what the books bit does what the
user's bit does what the distance is bit
does and everything else and the same
thing when you have your redock code
here
and so we can drill that we can see that
the authorization for this is auth zero
we can see that's the flow type there
client credentials there's our token URL
there's our implicit authorization URL
we have our response which is going to
be application Json and it's going to be
an array of these object types and
we have all the things that we can do in
there so that's redoc and I was quite
chuffed oh and over here on the right
it's got sort of sample Json for each of
those uh methods so uh this is the
payload that we should be sending proper
examples because I actually took the
time to put proper examples in there so
it's not just randomly generating
strings
so I thought that was quite nice and
then I found elements
um
elements
so
elements this is this uses web
components uh it's by stoplight it is
open source and elements uh breaks
things down like this it looks quite a
lot like redock until you go into let's
say books and let's say add a completed
book here
okay so we can see over here our auth is
going to be token and our body this is
an example thing we actually have send
API requests if I authenticate using
this and because I've put the URL to
authenticate with auth zero it will go
and do that bounce around the URL not
going to do it right now because all
zero gets weird about
um conference Wi-Fi
uh but uh and we can see it's got
roughly the same set of things here
we've got the responses that it might
return
um and everything else but then come
over here
and we go okay so here's how to send a
request to this API from JavaScript
using XML HTTP request uh here's how to
do it using fetch is jQuery something
else uh here's how to do it from python
in Python 3 or using requests here's how
to do it in C sharp using HTTP client or
using restsharp so if I want to call
this using an HTTP client I can just oh
look there's a copy button so people can
copy and paste wherever they're using
your API from they can copy and paste
the code from the elements documentation
into their application and they can call
your API using that I love elements it's
fantastic
so
there's a bunch of stuff that I'm kind
of noodling with and building to make
this work properly the one that's kind
of out there and and you can do things
with it is open API dot web
uh because obviously if you're just
going to hand code your open API file
and then dump it into your project you
need a way to serve that out and so open
api.web lets you embed that as a static
resource and then it will serve it out
and it will also serve the Swagger UI
HTML and JavaScript and CSS it will also
serve either redoc or elements or both
if you want both I'll show you how that
looks in the startup code for this
project
so if we go to
API here and SRC
and program
I've commented out the swashbuckle code
so
we no longer need an endpoints API
Explorer and we no longer need Swagger
gen we just have our normal stuff there
we no longer need use Swagger and use
Swagger UI we can just replace those
with this okay it's big I'm working on
same defaults
and and other ways of doing this uh but
um so you specify the assembly that's
got the resource in it and then the path
to the resource uh in that assembly so
that's the embedded resource and then we
can put some open API options on there
we can say this is version one uh the UI
path prefix is Swagger the Json path is
going to be here the yaml path is going
to be here if what you embed is yaml it
will convert it to Json and vice versa
so it will serve both kinds and then I
can say I want elements documentation by
specifying this element section and just
saying Swagger V1 docs
and then that returns a normal routing
uh sort of app thing so you can put on
allow Anonymous and calls and anything
else you might want to do on any of the
endpoints that are generated in there
okay
um
stuff that I am working on
uh
some analyzers so
at the moment the the big argument that
people sort of come back with is yes but
if I want to change my API now I have to
change it in two places and what if they
get out of sync
um and uh yes I can sort of see that I
mean you know just don't you're a
grown-up do things properly uh but also
if your design and implementation are
both in the same place and they're wrong
that just means you're wrong twice in
one place
um
that makes sense yes it does
but no I'm working on some analyzers
that will look at your open api.yaml
file and then say are you actually
implementing that can I find where
you're returning a 401 or a 403 or a 404
can I uh does the object you're
accepting is the body of this request
actually matched to what you specified
in the schema and can I put red
squiggles under there and can I generate
warnings that you can then set as errors
so your web application won't build if
it doesn't match the specification I
think that could be quite useful I'm
building a bundler in.net so you don't
have to install node to bundle your yaml
into a single file
um I'm working on a test thing where you
can write the tests in yaml so it looks
quite a lot like an open API file and
then it generates X unit tests based on
that and then the really fun one and the
thing that I think is potentially the
most interesting is some code gen
because remember I showed you the Proto
file and the way grpc works and it
generates the model classes and the
stubs for the service class so you get
something you maintain those Proto files
but you get something in exchange it's
the other way around you're not sort of
generating the information from the code
it generates code from the information
and so I started looking at ways of
doing that now there are quite a few
tools out there for things like node and
Python and so forth that you can say
here's my open API file generate me a
flask application and it will do the
skeleton it will sort of scaffold out
that application for you but it'll do it
once and then you change the
specification it won't update you right
it can't rewrite the code that it's
already written so it's a kind of use
once thing so what I'm working on is
something that will generate the model
classes for you and then generate a base
class very much like the grpc service
based class and then you implement that
and then there's a library that will
hook it up using minimal API so it'll
run just in a Docker container or as a
service on app services or whatever else
but also another package that will hook
it up to Azure functions and so it'll
generate functions for each of those
things another one that will hook it up
to AWS Lambda and make this open so that
people can get it to hook up to whatever
they want then if you change your spec
it regenerates the base class and
potentially the model types and then if
there's a breaking change your
application won't compile and you'll
have a pretty good clue that you should
be calling this version two as well so
that's something I'm working on too
I'm very happy to talk more about this
I'm around for the rest of the day I'm
doing the lock mode at the end of the
day so if you've got any questions then
please grab me outside rather than
coming on here because it's weird
standing up here and ask answering
questions but yes have I changed
anybody's mind is anybody going to go
back and and try doing this
I suck
who's going to carry on using
swashbuckle or end swag
yeah well baby steps baby steps
I'll get there in the end
that's it thank you very much for
listening to me and I'll see you at the
end of the day cheers